CBS News legal analyst Ricky Kleman is
with with us Ricky good morning
how serious are the charges these
parents are facing very serious we're
dealing with mail fraud wire fraud
conspiracy to commit these crimes and
what you have here are two schemes you
have the cheating that is the test
taking or the paying for others to take
the test the scoring of the test and
then you have the one that's really
complicated which is showing that your
children are athletes when they're not
so that they get in as they put it
through a side door since the kids
didn't know about it a lot of the kids
do they still get to stay in school well
it's an interesting question Gail I
think the parents are facing serious
time and perhaps when I mean by that is
prison time you go to jail for this
we're talking to parents yeah and I
don't think that we should look away
from that before I get to the children
because the people are so angry all over
the country about this case yeah so the
parents need to be punished severely in
order for there to be deterrence now
let's look at the kids some of the kids
really didn't know but you also have to
believe that some of the kids did know
and so are they going to be criminally
prosecuted possibly but highly unlikely
so what happens to them in college if
they're in college now isn't the remedy
with the college does the college expel
them how about the people who already
got degrees does the college then just
decide to re sing those degrees because
then it spins on to to employment
you know because everything has been
falsified since the beginning these
parents did their children no favors
thank you College Admissions is like
when you're facing jail time you throw
money and a problem if you have a lot of
problems couldn't somebody just lawyer
up with a lot of fancy expensive lawyers
and get out of this no one's getting out
of this one John there's too much
attention put to it it's one thing to
buy your way out of or buy your way into
education for your children which I find
appalling and disgusting frankly but
it's another thing at this stage to just
think you can buy a fancy lawyer and get
out of this these parents probably had
no thought that at some point they would
go to what's the likelihood there are
more Williams singers out there well
there probably are more Williams singers
out there and think
the irony of going after the kingpin
first and then going down I find that
fascinating he's facing 65 years looking
to try and bring it down through his
cooperation he says he's done this for
800 parents so we are at the tip of the
iceberg with 33 Oh God I think of all
the students though that didn't get in
that should have gotten that there's
thought was taken and that's what makes
people angry at the elites and the
wealthy this is going to exacerbate that
divide yeah thank you
say what you really think Ricky cleaning
it's early in the morning